welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday the aviation industry was among
the hardest hit by the coronavirus
pandemic
for months government support has kept
many airlines from furloughing or laying
off their employees
but that support is coming to an end and
with it the reprieve the thousands of
workers relied on
chris van cleef has the story american
airlines flight attendant phillip
delhunty will be out of a job
furloughed on thursday we got the
the furlough notice it was devastating
for everybody american started the year
as the world's largest airline with
about 140
000 employees kovit has devastated its
business
when the government's payroll support
program runs out next week
american will be 30 percent smaller
overnight
19 thousand will lose their jobs and 15
cities
will lose their service ceo doug parker
i just
can't believe that we need we may not be
able to do the right thing simply
because our elected officials
can't come to any sort of compromise
agreement
we're better than that in a show of
unity outside the capitol this week
airline ceos union leaders and employees
pleaded with congress for another 25
billion in payroll support to halt as
many as 76
000 furloughs and layoffs through at
least march
this is real people moving their stuff
into their cars and trying to figure out
how to survive for flyers
the furloughs could mean longer travel
times and fewer options
critics say giving the airlines more
money won't necessarily
save jobs because they're preparing for
potentially
a four year recovery united ceo scott
kirby disagrees
we will be ready to bounce back even if
it's not 100 percent we won't need all
of that support
but we need support to get through until
the vaccine is available and widely
distributed
there is rare bipartisan support in
congress and the white house that
something should be done
but a covet relief package remains
stalled as is a senate bill focused
solely on airline aid
americans are hurting and we need things
that work efficiently
to get them help we absolutely cannot
let an entire sector
of the economy collapse for dell hunty
political gridlock means an uncertain
countdown to potential
unemployment for cbs this morning
saturday
chris van cleave washington